[Music]
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is
overrated that's right this is happening
okay so why is this not just a steaming
pile of clickbait hear me out so far
there have been twenty of these movies
and uber producer Kevin Feige says there
will be at least 20 more in the MCU
Marvel Cinematic Universe within the
next 10 years
seriously half of these people could
disappear and it would still be a
hundred and forty-eight too many
characters when we asked Fox's audience
for things they think are overrated
Marvel and DC's movies came up again and
again we love these movies in the United
States alone they've grossed more than
6.5 billion dollars and yet there's
something missing when you look at the
history of fictional universes and at
the MCU in particular it's possible to
understand how could be fixed
[Music]
go back to 1939 and you'll find the
likely birth of the Marvel Universe
it's in marvel mystery comics number
seven these characters aren't that
well-known today but here Betty tells
Namor that the Human Torch exists
establishing continuity and crossover
potential this was the start of a new
era one in which corporations produced
fiction the idea was simple you could
use the fame of one property to enhance
the audience for another and Marvel
wasn't alone in recognizing the
financial opportunity of crossovers in
the 1930s and 40s
[Music]
but Green Hornet look at that picture on
the wall the man on that horse is one of
your ancestor in the 1940s the Green
Hornet revealed that the series central
character breed was the grand nephew of
the Lone Ranger
another popular radio star at the time I
hope you'll do something about those
crooks just does your pioneer ancestor
did movie studios were thinking about
this too when Abbott and Costello Meet
Frankenstein it joined the Dracula
Frankenstein and Wolfman movie
franchises with a goofy comedy it was
basically Universal Studios Avengers
infinity war but with more running into
walls by the 60s even DC Comics was
catching up like when Superman entered
his Fortress of Solitude and finally met
Batman
they enjoyed some cake
by the time spider-man got his comic in
1963 he was spending time with the
Fantastic Four and promoting guest
appearances from the Hulk and this was
also when the Marvel Universe's problems
started this snow globe contains a
half-century of television it's the
basis for the Tommy Westfall universe
theory which some argue might be the
biggest fictional universe of all the
snow globe appeared on the 80's
television show st. elsewhere that scene
possibly showed that the whole series
had taken place inside a snow globe
world imagined by a minor character
named Tommy Westfall the theory is that
a face show had a crossover with st.
elsewhere that show must have taken
place in Tommy's snow globe too and
every crossover that show had no matter
how tangential would be in the snow
globe and so on and so on until you get
almost 450 television shows in the same
universe in the same snow globe it's
fans from 1952 to today it's a dumb
theory but it's meant to be that said
the Tommy westphall universe actually
illustrates some of the problems with
the Marvel Cinematic Universe crossovers
require a bunch of artistic compromises
no one wants cheers and I Love Lucy to
be a connected universe it's because a
bunch of business decisions connected
them
sometimes the network force crossovers
on producers other times the producers
came up with it Gary Marshall said that
the reason that Mork from ork knew
Fonzie from Happy Days and Laverne from
Laverne and Shirley was because his son
said that Fonzie should dream about an
alien
these crossovers are always about
juicing ratings not telling a good story
the Tommy westphall universe is a
thought experiment Frasier and the
x-files don't mix even though they do in
Tommy West Falls globe but even at
Marvel where continuity was planned it
became a hassle to maintain Marvel
editor and writer Lynn ween said the
problem at Marvel was that we suddenly
became a business with a bunch of books
that Stan don't think ever in his heart
expected to last more than a couple of
years in 1965 Lee replaced most of the
Avengers just because the continuity for
the original group had become too
confusing to deal with this continuity
clutter happened in the movies too
Iron Man kicked off the MCU in 2008 the
universe exposition dump didn't happen
until after the credits mr. stark you
become part of a bigger universe ant-man
required a weak excuse right in the
middle of the movie I think our first
move should be calling The Avengers I
spent half my life trying to keep this
technology out of the hands of the Stark
I'm sure as hell not gonna hand-deliver
it to one now these heavy-handed
additions are about getting crossover
hype not about telling a good story but
there's a bigger problem than continuity
in the MCU and there is a way to do it
better the rest of this scene is a
standard movie fight their universe is
only as deep as some merchandise and a
few Easter eggs it's cool when Peter
Parker's classroom has a picture of
Bruce Banner in the corner but it's not
a transformed universe
it's like Quentin Tarantino including
the imaginary brand of red Apple
cigarettes in multiple movies it's cool
it
not a coherent intertwined world the MCU
is like our own except for the
crossovers you can test it with the
characters add Aquaman to that poster if
you didn't know DC owned him would
anyone notice the MCU has no rules
beyond corporate ownership it's a
superhero hodgepodge the same goes for
DC if you added Hawkeye here nobody
would care and not just because it's
Hawkeye Marvel's own property x-men with
a movie universe owned by Fox and likely
going to Disney shows a better way this
universe is not just crossovers every
character human and mutant has taken
sides in a generations-long battle with
real stakes
unlike Marvel Civil War that leads to
creative possibilities like decade
jumping and even tonal experimentation
with deep integration to the x-men
mythology if not the continuity when
Marvel experiments like with Jessica
Jones the big tie-in to the MCU is merch
cool toys in your room you want to show
me do you know Captain America x-men
movies are not all good but they do have
a universal logic that is stronger than
Tommy West falls snow globe
here's another task if you little old
you we're in a movie which universe
would change you in x-men you'd have to
decide where you fell in a decades-long
battle do you side with mutants or
humans in the MCU you'd be like this kid
in agents of shield your big decision
would be to buy some merch okay
Marvel has flirted with a richer
universe one in which the lives of all
people are transformed by a shared
history but right now would anybody be
surprised if Disney forced a Marvel Star
Wars crossover
Marvel and Disney can make the right
choice in the late 80s the Marvel comic
damage-control toyed with the
consequences of superhero life on the
world at large now made its cameo in
spider-man homecoming a thrilling
indicator of where the MCU could go it
was a world that anybody could imagine
themselves in but until that
experimentation transforms the movies
the MCU is just a business strategy the
universe is still in development if you
want just the facts about Marvel please
check out Sean house Marvel Comics the
untold story it gives you a peek behind
the scenes of Marvel and how they shaped
a half century of our culture